Harry here back with another Sundance
2019 interview we are super excited
because we have finally broken out the
beers we are feeling pretty good right
now
we have Kia Telluride who is sponsoring
this whole thing so we get to talk about
really cool projects like now apocalypse
so a lot of our viewers out there have
absolutely no clue what your show is
about so I guess Carly maybe I'll pose
this to you can you give a brief
synopsis of now apocalypse pressure okay
someone or nobody wants to do it so it's
a show about a group of friends who live
in LA and they're in their twenties and
they're sort of figuring out their lives
and having a lot of experimental sex in
the process in the midst of a looming
alien conspiracy that may or may not be
real in mayor it may be real but it may
be the hallucinations of our main
character Ulysses and that's pretty much
it that's good right yeah
okay so now we got a run through
everybody in the cast right now huge
ensemble here super colorful characters
but I don't want it I know like I could
not stand looking at them the entire
time i screen these episodes which is a
big fat lie but I don't want to ask you
guys to describe your character so
instead let's spin it this way give me
one quality about your character that
you'd like to keep for yourself
sexual astronaut I would say sports what
you want to go with moaning what are you
going with sexual astronaut I do like
that that applies to a lot of the cast
the trumpet spontaneity like I don't
know a little less care about that's
like a lot of words that's not one word
like carefree oh that's a lame mic the
mic should really should matter rights
but if you talk into the beer bottles or
the water bottles that works too every
rowdy here it's a Lassiter view of this
yeah this is Evans we roll into an
interview I said I wanted to be I wanted
to trumpet my character isn't a punk
band okay this is the most chaotic
interview this is how we do all of our
interviews we just all talk at once it's
really okay Ford it has a big heart and
I heart it's an appropriate way are you
saying are you saying you don't have a
heart bow I do I'm the guy the launch
team in the lion what was the key
courage sexualize not the lion the short
story I feel like we could stop this
interview now in those two descriptions
would just sell everybody come on
so if you like lions sexual exploration
come on by clearly this show is all over
the place there's crazy things happening
Griego what was like the one thing that
inspired the whole idea where did it
start
I mean I just want to make a show the
original idea for the show is I just
wanted to make a show that was totally
unlike any other show and it's really
the show is really like my dream show up
and want to make a show like this for
about 20 years and I just wanted to do
show that was totally unlike everything
else and just like my imagination kind
of just went crazy and it was actually a
weird coincidence is that I had met Aven
for the short film that we did together
and I'm sort of I'm same timing that
Carly for this she's written a feature
script that I was attached to direct and
produce and I met both of them and I
just both they both really I just fell
in love with both of them they're just
fun and cooled
and I started thinking about well if we
do a show and I'm always going to make
sort of a Sex in the City kind of girls
kind of show about sex and relationships
it's like what if there was sort of a
queer Avan Jogia and he's friends with
somebody sort of like a Carly and they
get together and you know and then he's
got a roommate and Ford and then four
does a girlfriend Severine and I work
with Roxanne on kaboom and so I wrote
the part of seven for her and it's from
these four people like this whole sort
of crazy world of nail polish come on so
glad we have a director that was the
most succinct it was really good what
does it mean to be premiering the show
here at Sundance because as someone who
really loves foam festivals it's been
really exciting to see the TV
episodic lineups getting out to every
single festival yeah I mean it's really
just so personal personally meaningful
to me to premiere here because I was
first accenting something like 1992 with
my films living in like early like 25
years ago and you know that film was
like the 16-millimeter kind of punk rock
like underground movie about these gay
lovers and it was very controversial but
you know just seen as this very out of
the mainstream weird thing and now to be
back here you know 25 26 years later
with this show which is still in its own
way very kind of punk rock and very true
to its spirit Soderbergh last night
called it What did he say it was
unquestionably yeah it was like there's
no like there's no compromise to it it's
just like pure kind of creative vision
and like exactly what we want it to be
and here we are Sundance you know this
shows ten episodes of stars starting
March 10th and it's so crazy to me that
the culture has changed that like
Sundance has grown so much and the
culture has changed so much that from
1992 till now it's like from the living
into now clubs it's like a whole world
so one thing we like to do here at
Collider is play games and one of my
favorite games is would you rather but
all film making TV related questions but
with a Sundance
in this round so I love first would you
rather see your show or your movie
before its Festival premiere or go into
the screening completely blind which is
actually an interesting question with
the material I mean I'd like to see it
on a big big big fancy screen with the
sound and the thing in the you know it's
so it's there's not like a mumbly
soft-focus people talking about their
problems hand cam sort of film it's like
fun and Shotwell and great and electric
and so you want to see it like properly
but the good thing about the small
screen big screen thing is I think you
did a good job is like on your laptop
and they'll be like it'll just pop as
well you know no good you know we talked
today who's seen the third episode the
stars folks are very kind with their
media room well they're sending links
over here really are anyone else want to
chime in on that one I got another one
here I'll give you a new one bow anyway
would you rather walk around Sundance
with no gloves or wet boots no gloves no
clutter in the question boots your
questions see nope no pants no gloves
because Weiner out all right RJ I'm
giving you one now would you rather meet
a new collaborator at a film festival or
reconnect with someone you worked with
before
get laid oh no you know I actually I
love reconnecting thank every this is my
sixth time at Sundance and every I still
have that core group of fans from the
first Sundance to the second to the
third and even here and I've been seeing
friends through this whole week and it's
always special because festivals like
this we all once we leave here we all go
home really we all have separate
identities and these things bring us
together and they allow us to continue
not just on set and shooting but but
after and that camaraderie I love glad
somebody came ready to answer proper
questions give this one to but someone
just jump in all right Tyler this one's
all yours coffee would you rather
trumpet would you rather do festival
interviews with a co-star who talks too
much or not enough
Abin talks way too much I don't probably
not enough not to probably somebody who
doesn't talk too much I guess I don't
know I don't really care most chaotic
interviewers ever
I'm just whirling ball of apocalypse
energy rolling around Sunday I I do it
with somebody who could talks a lot then
we can bounce off each other I talk a
lot to you and I will shut up because I
had to top you would you rather have to
eat a lot in a scene or run the entire
scene oh my god
but then you gotta do all the takes with
all the food or was it just me eating
the fruit loose
you ate all the fruit loops remember how
we got loopy it was like one of the last
scenes we ever shot true
I didn't actually that was crazy no
there came a point where I'm like cuz I
was hungry when I started the scene so
many and then I started going crazy and
like what are my lines like very full
gonna throw up
so you're supposed to fake it with a
little itty bitty bites that nobody can
tell yeah you know I was hungry I don't
know what I don't know what I choose how
long is the scene how long are we
running for that I mean that's that's
the would you rather of it all you got
to take the risk there he'll run it's
good for me I believe in you would you
rather have to fake sneeze or fake vomit
in a scene vomit
I real vomit in all of the scenes I'm in
come on it's not that sad here was just
telling us about someone they know that
could vomit on cue so I would believe it
how many fake or would you rather have
two very orgasm or fake sneeze I have
two Roxanne has too many your whole line
is change your question it's about
organizer I only wish that I could take
that version of the question and apply
it anywhere else but then they would
look at me like I was crazy
or kicked me out of the room it's like a
really serious drama like so how many
fake or guests did you have let's say I
feel like the fake sneeze verse fake
orgasm question is actually valid
because it's not easy to do it
realistically well I guess you guys
would know better than I would
last one year
would you rather attend a festival with
a crowd-pleaser or a more challenging
film or show challenging challenging you
can what does it seem like to you I'd
rather do the fake orgasm because it
seemed like to you having had our
conversation with us that's actually a
reasonable question I get the vibe that
it is crowd pleaser but the show the
show is kind of challenging because like
you guys know I'm three episodes in but
I'm still piecing together kind of the
meaning and how everybody's changing
very kind of punk-rock and very kind of
out there and it has the kind of David
Lynch element to it it's very it has
challenging aspects to it in the second
portrayal sexuality but it's really fun
and it's really cool and it's just it's
really like candy crazy colorful yeah
it's like a yeah and I think that when
the show comes out it's like I wish that
you can't binge the show till the very
end of the run they're gonna not release
all ten episodes until the very end but
at the end it's a very busy show because
you can just sort of be like candy
perfect tease right they're perfect
place to end this interview actually I
feel like we need one choice
so now apocalypse into the final
interview of Sundance 2019 thank you
guys so much for your time thank you for
watching this interview thank you to Kia
Telluride for making this craziness
happen like and share this interview
we'll see you soon
you